Hi,
Dr. Peterson.
Um,
so what the story of Jacob today,
there was a theme of betrayal and you
can see that from the beginning because
he was very angry and jealous of his
brother.
And I was thinking,
are there any stories or we can say
about betrayal that does come from a
loved one,
right?
Where it's not from a place of so black
and white of anger,
resentment and bitter,
and how the parties,
um,
kind of recover from that.
Or is there any way to reading dot.
Or is it as black and white us if you'll
be traced on one,
then there it's like Jacob where he's,
he was bitter.
He was planning
hatred,
no one.
And in fact,
in this story,
it's not black and white because we know
we're only halfway through it.
And,
um,
one of the things I've noticed as a
clinician,
let's say,
is that an,
as an observer of people in general,
is that I've never ever seen anyone get
away with anything.
And Jacob doesn't get away with any of
this.
And so,
um,
you know,
he's humbled by his eventual experiences
and he learns that he did it wrong.
And there's reconciliation that happens
throughout the story of Jacob.
So,
and there's minor betrayals and major be
trails.
You know,
that some of them have tremendously
serious consequences and some of them
have lesser consequences,
but there is an underlying idea that
things can still be set right.
Even though it's,
well,
I think it takes Jacob some 20 years,
something like that to set things right.
And even then,
it's like touch and go.
So if I answer your question,
okay,
yeah.